The Path Tracing Ray Type switch node can be used to replace material information for shadows, indirect specular, volume, and diffuse rays.
The Path Tracing Ray Type switch node lets you feed different material inputs depending on the ray type being traced.
We have camera, shadow, indirect diffuse, indirect specular, and volumetric.
It's a path tracing only node that we can add to our material that's used to fine tune how material behaves under different ray evaluations.
So in short, the node gives you a per ray type material control, allowing artists and TDs to reduce noise, improve render performance, or fine tune artistic or physically based behavior when using Unreal Engine's Path Tracer.
Now, if we jump over to the project, you'll see that I have applied here a quick debug material that I've created.
Now, before I show the material, one quick change you may have noticed is that the viewport is a little bit darker than normal.
And all I've done is simply gone to my perspective and under game settings, I've just unchecked it and adjusted my EV.
So if I turn this on, these are the settings that the scene will use.
So if the level has a post processing volume, it will use those post processing volume settings.
Or by simply unchecking it, I can manually override it.
So that's the only difference here. And that's just to help better visualize and see this material.
Now, if I bring the material over, I'll leave this up on screen so you can see it's a very basic material.
And if I click the material or the empty graph, I'm going to go over to my details panel and click the little settings cog and do show only modified properties.
And this will show you the properties that I have changed outside of just the basic material.
So from the previous sections, you should be comfortable creating a basic material, going into these properties and changing them.
And then, of course, adding properties like our single scalars or our three scalars.
And if you notice here is our path tracing ray type switching node that we have been discussing.
So from here, I've just simply plugged in various colors and then applied it to our debug sphere.
And then I can start to visualize how the engine is processing all of those different passes.
All right. In the next section, we're going to cover some of the post processing material buffers and how we can modify those to our liking.